الحرب في اوكرانيا اذا اضافه الى التوتر
في شرق اسيا كان مدخلا لازمه كبيره فيما
يعرف باشباه الموصلات او الرقائق
الالكترونيه التي يحتاجها العالم في كثير
من الصناعات الاساسيه الولايات المتحده
واحده من البلدان التي تواجه هذا المازق
حيث تعتمد بنسبه كبيره على تايوان لتامين
هذه الوريده لكن الرئيس الامريكيه جو
بايدن قال امس الثلاثاء ان ادارته تعمل
على استعاده الصداره في هذه الصناعه على
الصعيد العالمي
اماكن
الولايات المتحده هي من اخترعت الرقائق
الالكترونيه نحن من اخترعناها بفضل
برنامجنا للفضاء على مدى 30 عاما كانت
امريكا تصنع 40% من انتاج الرقائق العالمي
ثم حصل شيء ما واصبح العمود الفقري
الاقتصادنا ايواف وبدل انتقال المنتجات
بدات الشركات والوظائف تنتقل الى خارج
الحدود ونتيجه لذلك نحن اليوم نصنع حوالي
عشره في المئه فقط من الانتاج العالمي
للرقائق الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]